I had about five minutes before I was
set to deliver a talk to a bunch of
business owners about visibility and
being on camera after all I was the
so-called expert there
the former 20 year television news
anchor and life and business coach I
happen to take a look down at my cell
phone just to catch the time and I
noticed that I had a missed call from my
ex-husband I can still hear his voice
Darius
what is going on I just got a call from
some strange man who told me to go to
this website and now I'm looking at all
of these photos of you naked your
private parts are all over this website
who's seen this I couldn't think I
couldn't breathe I was so humiliated and
so embarrassed and so ashamed I felt
like my world was coming to an end and
yet this began for me months of pain and
depression and anger and confusion and
silence my manipulative jealous stalker
ex-boyfriend did exactly what he said he
would do he put up a website with my
name on it and he posted this and this
and several explicit photos that he had
taken of me while I was asleep living
with him in Jamaica for months prior to
that he had been sending me threatening
text messages like this he was trying to
make me out to be some sleazy lowlife
[__] he'd even threatened to kill me he
told me that he would shoot me in my
head and stab me in my heart
simply because I wanted to end the
controlling relationship I couldn't
believe this was happening to me I
didn't even know what to call it you
might know it as cyber harassment or
cyber bullying the media calls it
revenge porn I now call it digital
domestic violence
it typically stems from a relationship
gone bad where a controlling jilted
ex-lover can't handle rejection so when
they can't physically put their hands on
you they use different weapons
cellphones and laptops the ammunition
photos videos explicit information
content all posted online without your
consent I mean let's face it we all live
our lives online
and the Internet is a really small world
we show off our baby photos we start and
grow our businesses we make new
relationships we let the world in one
Facebook like at a time and you know
what I found an even smaller world one
in 25 women say they have been impacted
by revenge porn for women under the age
of 30 that number looks like 1 in 10 and
that leaves a few of you in this
audience as potential victims you want
to know what's even more alarming lack
of legislation and laws to adequately
protect victims and punish perpetrators
there's only one federal bill pending
it's called the enough act by Senator
Kamala Harris it would criminalize
revenge porn but that could take years
to pass so what are we left with in the
meantime flimsy civil misdemeanors
currently only 40 states and DC have
some laws in place for revenge porn and
those penalties vary we're talking $500
fines
$500 are you kidding me women are losing
their jobs they're suffering from
damaged relationships and damaged
reputations they're falling into illness
and depression and the suicide rates are
climbing you're looking at a woman who
spent 11 months in court 13 trips to the
courthouse and thousands of dollars in
legal fees just to get to things a
protection from cyber stalking and cyber
abuse otherwise known as a PFA and
language from a judge that would force a
third party Internet company to remove
the content it's expensive complicated
and confusing and worse legal loopholes
and jurisdictional issues
act this out four months all my private
parts were on display for months how
would you feel if your naked body was
exposed for the world to see and you
waited helplessly for the content to be
removed
eventually I stumbled upon a private
company to issue a DMCA notice to shut
the website down DMCA Digital Millennium
Copyright Act it's a law that regulates
digital material and content broadly the
aim of the DMCA is to protect both
copyright owners and consumers so get
this people who take and share nude
photos own the rights to those selfies
so they should be able to issue a DMCA
to have the content removed but not so
fast because the other fight we're
dealing with is non-compliant and
non-responsive third party Internet
companies and oh by the way even in
consenting relationships just because
you get a nude photo or a naked pic does
not give you the right to share it even
with the intent to do harm back to my
case which happens to be further
complicated because he was stalking and
harassing me from another country making
it nearly impossible to get help here
but wait a minute isn't the internet
international shouldn't we have some
sort of policy in place that broadly
protects us regardless to borders or
restrictions I just couldn't give up I
had to keep fighting so I willingly on
three occasions allowed for the invasion
of both my cell phone and my laptop by
the Department of Homeland Security and
the Jamaican embassy for thorough
forensic investigation because I had
maintained all of the evidence I
painstakingly shared my private parts
with the all-male investigative team and
it was an embarrassing humiliating
additional hoop to jump through but then
something happened Jamaican authorities
actually arrested him he's now facing
charges under their malicious
Communications Act and if found guilty
could face thousands of dollars in fines
and up to ten years in prison and I've
also learned that my case is making
history it is the first international
case under this new crime Wow finally
some justice but this got me to thinking
nobody deserves this nobody deserves
this level of humiliation and having to
jump through all of these hoops our
cyber civil rights are at stake here in
the United States we need to have clear
tough enforcement we need to demand the
accountability and responsiveness from
online companies we need to promote
social responsibilities for posting
sharing and texting and we need to
restore victim dignity to victims and
what about victims who neither have the
time money or resources to wage war who
are left disempowered mislabeled and
broken two things release the shame and
in the silence shame is at the core of
all of this and for every silent
prisoner of shame it's the fear of
judgment that's holding you hostage and
the price to pay is the stripping away
of your self-worth the day I ended my
silence I freed myself from shame and i
freed myself from the fear of judgment
from the one person who I thought would
judge me the most my son who actually
told me mom you are the strongest person
that I know you can get through this and
besides mom he chose the wrong woman to
mess with
it was on that day that I decided to use
my platform and my story and my voice
and to get started I asked myself this
one simple question who do I need to
become now that question in the face of
everything that I was challenged with
transformed my life and had me thinking
about all kinds of possibilities
I now own my story I speak my truth and
I'm narrating a new chapter in my life
it's called Fifty Shades of silence it's
a global social justice project and
we're working to film an upcoming
documentary to give voice and dignity to
victims if you are a victim or you know
someone who is know this in order to be
empowered you have to take care of
yourself and you have to love yourself
you have to turn your anger into action
your pain into power and your setback
into a setup
for what's next for your life this is a
process and it's a journey of
self-discovery that might include
forgiveness but it definitely requires
bravery confidence and conviction I call
it finding your everyday courage thank
you
[Applause]